when myspace was a thing it was like
Facebook only it was MySpace and it was
basically the gangster janky version of
Facebook there was a thing called top
eight and you could have like your top
eight friends shown on your homepage so
I made fake profiles for my top eight
and I made them all Kurt Russell here's
how you know the Kurt Russell profiles
were fake if you clicked on any one of
those profiles you would see each one of
those profiles only had one friend and
they were me but one time this guy wrote
to quote-unquote Kurt Russell from Italy
he said I've seen all of your movies I
love your work you're my favorite actor
Kurt Russell I'm in Italy if there's
anything I can do to try and to audition
or be in your movie I would love to do
it this and I don't use this term
lightly brain-dead Italian [ __ ] thinks
that this is the real Kurt Russell hey
then it starts to dawn on me all of the
things that actors and struggling
artists that move to Hollywood have to
sacrifice and give up and they give up
everything just to hope to maybe get an
audition for some [ __ ] Kohl's
commercial you know I'm talking about
I'm getting mad at this guy because if
this guy oh I'm a huge fan I always want
to be an actor if there's anything I can
do if there's anything you could do move
the [ __ ] LA drop everything and try
you're not trying
so I write back as quote-unquote Kurt
Russell you seem like it got a good look
and you know if you really want to
audition for my next movie about race
cars why don't you do the scene from a
few good men where Jack Nicholson says
you can't handle the truth and send it
over to me in a link and if it's good
I'll cast you in my next movie about
race cars I'm not a bad guy for doing
this because if this guy actually thinks
I'm serious and is actually Kurt Russell
saying hey man you
audition for my race car movie put on a
[ __ ] monologue from a few good men
and he does it then guess what his fault
he sends me an audition of him doing the
scene from a few good men in his Italian
accent I'm watching it crying laughing
rolling around on my on my apartment
floor the dude had and I'm 95% sure was
wearing sunglasses off-screen he's
reading the monologue the disrespect
that this [ __ ] guy has try and get a
job in Hollywood by hitting up Kurt
Russell on MySpace and then [ __ ]
reading it off-screen trying to [ __ ]
throw me for a loop by just wearing
sunglasses I'm also angry that this
[ __ ] doing this because of how
everybody tries to [ __ ] give
everything up in the Hollywood okay and
try to [ __ ] you know make it I write
back as Kurt Russell pretty good but I
need to see something else too in my
race car movie I told you it's a race
car movie so I want you to have a big
fat mustache like a race car driver
would have I want you to wear a big hat
like a cowboy hat I need to see you get
shot and die because that's the see
that's there's a scene where you have to
get shot and die in the race car movie
and then he sends me another audition
tape of him reading whatever the [ __ ] it
is with [ __ ] of fake big moustache
and then it cuts to him next to his
doorway and he just goes and pretends he
got shot and then falls down and dies
dude if anybody could it find the Kurt
Russell audition that this guy did first
whatever race car movie I don't think he
put in race car in the title but maybe
Kurt Russell's in the title but I think
and his name is Michael I think he went
by Michael something dude it's the and
it's a few good men it's the best do it
it's so funny man